[Music]
what's going on guys we are back talking
about Sony's brand new 4k OLED TV the
a80k Bravia XR TV with the Bravia cam
that's right a camera that you can
attach to the TV is it a little bit
spooky to have in your bedroom we're
going to talk about the pros and the
cons by the way we are not sponsored or
paid by Sony for this review but we do
have a sponsor and that is Asus check it
out this video is brought to you by Asus
check out the Asus Zenbook 14x OLED
Space Edition commemorating the 25th
anniversary of the first Asus laptop
sent into space Not only does it offer a
space exclusive design but it's even
worthy of going where no man has gone
before with its space grade durability
it even comes with a 3.5 inch OLED
companion Zen Vision display and you
will have a ball of a time taking
interviews with a 16 by 10 4K OLED Nano
Edge Pantone validated 14 inch display
so let's get down to talking about it
first and for foremost it's 65 inches
for this variant right here there is a
77 inch variant and I would prefer to
have that in my bedroom versus the 65
reason being I currently have a 75 inch
TV that's being put on the shelf for the
last few weeks since I've been having
this in my room and testing it out and
as they say for TVs bigger is better but
speaking of which let's talk about the
performance of this TV because that's
what you guys are here to find out is it
worth buying is this the TV that you
need to have in your home well first and
foremost Sony makes some of the best TVs
out there in terms of black reproduction
this is something I noticed for my TV
way back when I first had a Sony HD TV
not even 4K OLED and the blacks are
beautiful you can see the details
nothing looks crushed or it doesn't look
too contrasty it is really well
calibrated right out of the box now of
course you can calibrate these TVs to be
how you want them to be these are Google
Android TVs so a lot of the settings
that you're going to see on other
Android TVs will come into play here but
you have also Sony's UI which is really
impressive but speaking of calibration
this is really easy to work with on this
TV set and I have to tell you honestly
with the settings that Sony already had
in the TV I was pretty much up and going
in no time flat and I found that I found
the color profiles that I liked they
were very easy Vivid is a little bit too
Vivid for me so I like to go standard or
Cinema but as I mentioned the blacks are
absolutely beautiful and now talk about
the pixels on this TV they are really
this is a really good TV when you're
watching 4K HDR 10 plus all that great
stuff you're watching Netflix you're not
going to see pixels even close up the
pixel density is fantastic on this
display it is breathtakingly beautiful
and I think any of you out there who are
pixel peepers you're going to be more
than happy what Sony's doing with this
80k television set it is awesome but
let's talk about the Android TV
interface and of course we'll get to the
Bravia cam which is going to be a topic
of uh I think consideration for some if
you're going to want to get that or not
but anyway let's talk about the
performance this is a very fast TV now
my TV of reference is a xiaomi qled TV
which of course is at a different price
price point at 75 inches but comparing
it to this Sony they are just night and
day the responsiveness from Google Voice
to just navigation to go into your
settings to just your daily usage this
TV is blazing fast I've found no hiccups
I've found no freezing I found no issues
with this TV whatsoever and I want to
show you what the settings look like on
this as well because the settings if you
go to your quick settings it's so easy
to find everything you want to find
except the Google Play Store that's
something that adds an Android TV issue
not necessarily a Sony issue but you
cannot find that without actually
digging deep with inside the menu or
using Google Assistant to find Google
Play or ask to open it up and then you
will find that to download your
applications but outside of that this
menu system is great now let's talk
about the Bravia cam for a moment here
Bravia cam this is going to be a topic
of consideration for some do you want to
have a camera on your TV especially when
it's placed in your bedroom now if
you're in an office setting or in a room
that you have no need for privacy no
issues at all the Broadway Cam and then
Sony's done some really good jobs of
addressing privacy first and foremost
you can turn off the camera with a
physical uh button that will actually
put a shutter over the camera system so
that means it will not work and the TV
will let you know that the Broadway cam
is not active when it is active you can
do a variety of things you can do
gesture control it can actually detect
where you're sitting in terms of
brightness for the television in terms
of audio you can use it as a webcam for
Google meets or Skype or whatever you
want to use in terms of your
applications and it works relatively
well it's a little bit slow but it does
detect your hand or other people's hands
in the room because it scans the entire
room and it notices hands so it's
responsive in that way but look to be
honest with you this will do it probably
faster and quicker but again if you're
really lazy let's say you left the
controller in another room and you don't
want to go up and get it you're in bed
you're like I'm tired I don't want to
get that controller or oh screw it I'll
just raise my hand here we go then you
can do that but uh it can only do
certain uh functions it can't control
everything on the TV so keep that in
mind but what I do like about this is it
actually has
um this sort of person detection in the
room so let's say you leave the room for
a period of time it will then turn off
the TV now it won't turn off right away
because sometimes we leave our room you
know grab a drink go to the restroom
whatever it may be and it won't turn off
the TV right away it'll wait a few
minutes but if it detects that people
are not coming back to the bedroom or
back to the respective room after a
certain period of time then it will turn
off it also detects light our ambient
Light Within the room and it will adjust
the settings what's inside the TV also
audio as well as I mentioned so it does
some really cool things but again some
people may not want to have a camera in
their bedroom like I have right here I
mean it's a little bit creepy it kind of
is Sony's done their best for the
Privacy control but
it's going to be an option of contention
for some of you out there but besides
that I do applaud Sony for the
technology that they are adding inside
of it and I think over time with
firmware updates it will become more
responsive and it will become more
usable over time but right now it just
seems more of a kind of a hey guys this
is what I have on my TV versus something
that I would actually use but speaking
of assistance let's talk about Google
assistant on this bad boy it is
phenomenal it is so responsive and so
quick case in point hey Google open up
Disney Plus
there it is
open up YouTube app
opening YouTube first of all yes I stand
by
see how quick it is hey Google search
Geek culture videos on YouTube
sure here are some videos
there's our Channel there
and there we are that's how responsive
this is now let's talk about the sound
out of this TV because it is very
impressive and if you have never tried a
Sonya Bravia TV in the last couple years
the speakers are kind of behind the
screen and it comes through it very
similar to what we see when we're in a
theater in a movie theater for that
matter and the sound is beautiful it's
it fills the room nicely now I have a
sound bar here which because I have a
kind of a like mini theater system in my
room but even using the stock speakers
is fantastic so if you do not have a
sound system which I would recommend
getting because if you want to get a TV
like this great sound is a plus it
definitely will make a difference now
speaking of sound there's also a setting
inside the TV to actually enhance the
clarity of someone's voice so let's say
you're watching a documentary or even if
you're watching a movie there's a lot of
other sounds out there some TVs will
kind of muddle it all together Sony will
differentiate the vocal uh audio versus
the surrounding audio which will help in
that way so it's kind of hard to depict
the sound on YouTube here but if you go
to let's say one of those electronic
Superstores or a demo store try it out
you'll see what I'm talking about it is
awesome another attribute that I like
about this TV or where the ports are at
now on some TVs the ports are underneath
now depending where you set up your TV
that can be very difficult if you do not
have a mounting system where you can
pull the TV out and rotate it it will be
very hard to get uh to plug things
inside the TV that way Sony actually has
it on the left side of the TV right here
and it's very easy to get to and there's
actually a little bit of space so if you
have larger hands like myself you can
plug those uh respective cables in there
we have HDMI cables we have Optical we
have ethernet USB uh you're pretty much
covered in various different ports
whatever you want to connect to this TV
they've got you covered and it's I'm
glad they have it on the side versus
underneath makes a world of difference
now in terms of the resolution on this
you can max out at 4K 120 hertz so if
you guys are into gaming as I mentioned
before or they will play up to 4K 120
hertz if they have any gameplay that you
want to take advantage of that but again
Sony would optimize this TV for the PS5
because guys it's Sony and Sony
why wouldn't they one thing I do like
about this TV as well is because I use
iPhones and iPads and MacBook Pros as I
have apple AirPlay built into this as
well as Chromecast so you were covered
in any which way you want to stream
content and it works flawlessly on all
those ways as a matter of fact sometimes
I'm watching a video on my phone on my
iPhone I come into my room I say is this
do you want to stream it to the TV why
yes I do because I'm lazy that way so I
just press the button it streams up
there and I'm good golden beautiful
synchronization inside the Broadway xrtv
and Chromecast because of course it's
Google has to work with Chromecast right
right that is my Roundup on this TV
would I recommend it yes I think the
picture quality is absolutely fantastic
um I know there's a lot of OLED TVs out
there and there's a lot of competition
but what you're seeing from Sony is
going to be uh one of the best picture
reproductions out there for a lot of
content that you're watching especially
if you're into cinema and movies high in
4k content you're going to really enjoy
what this produces it's beautiful it's
breathtaking and it's gonna be sad to
let it go to be honest with you but 65
inches for me is a little bit small 77
that's the size I would go with if you
go for this uh model or a series of
model for the Sony Bravia xrtv so with
that guys those are my thoughts if you
like this video check out more of our
reviews right
here or here get I don't know somewhere
[Music]